Frankfurt's famous rumor building has
been transformed or is it just a trick
of the light words and abstract patterns
form and reform on the facade of the
15th century former town hall and on
rubrics square onlookers become part of
this installation light artist Philip
Geist's video mapping show called
Frankfort facades tells stories about
the city in preparation city residents
sent him words that they associate was
their room our barrack square it's fun
sometime in some of the terms were in
Hessian dialect so I had to learn what
they meant I didn't know what they meant
I was in topography there were also
terms like book-burning 33 respect or
together or Cheers
[Music]
they sent in words with all kinds of
associations
[Music]
another of the city's landmarks the
antipope our concert hall held a
premiere of a very different kind its
facade served as the screen for changing
times a light artwork by the car Makena
designed collected in at the Milan
artists tell the story of the Opera
House in five acts the ten-minute show
covers the decades from its dedication
in October 1882 its destruction in the
bombings of world war ii and its
resurrection as the city's famous
concert hall the great value of this
project and effort comes from the
combination of new methods with old
materials new technologies we succeeded
in telling the story of the theater and
we used old documents gathered from
Frankfurt's museums to do some these
were photos illustrations and videos the
lumen Allah takes place every two years
it's also known as the biennial for
light art and urban design it lasts for
six days the aim is not just to dazzle
visitors but to encourage them to
rediscover the city and think about
sustainable urban development I always
thought I knew Frankfurt very well even
the parts of it that lie off the beaten
track this year's festival included
installations are happening in places I
had completely forgotten about and the
event spotlights history and information
that one might not have even been aware
of I'm sober Worcester on one venue is
st. Catherine's Church the project
Catalina and pacion by Viennese artist
Victoria Cohen has transformed it into a
multi-faceted work that involves light
sound and silence a space that visitors
can explore and linger in
the project examines the role that
churches play in the public spaces of
today's cities for missing the same day
to me they are vast spaces gifted to the
public in the middle of the city where
you can find peace and refuge where your
mind can wander especially with this
Catalina and pacion project it gives
visitors a space to relax and then head
back into the world fortified bolstered
by the time they had to be alone with
their thoughts the church's patron saint
is st. Catherine of Alexandria and the
piece is also dedicated to her she was a
fourth century philosopher who was put
to death for her Christian faith she
stands for an inner strength and courage
the lumen Allah is also meant to have a
lasting impact so what's left once the
two hundred thousand expected visitors
have left and the lights have gone out
we hope that the event will lead many
positive impressions that it will have
inspired discussions that will still be
relevant after the festival and that
will feed into decisions made by the
city about the city and how it's
changing thus pundits their stance on a
need to construct
and the people of Frankfurt's can
already start looking forward to yet
another inspiring lumen Allah in two
years time